basmati rice the king of all rice is
light fluffy delicious and i'm going to
show you how to cook it perfectly
now
start off with
400 grams of rice
rice in
spot on
so what i'm gonna do now is just rinse
off the dust and the starch
cold water always
and just rinse
the rice
that stops the rice from becoming clumpy
in the pan and allows it to become
really nice light and fluffy once it's
cooked rice
into the pan now to make a plain fluffy
rice exciting we're going to infuse it
three cardamom pods
and just get the pods and just pierce
them so it allows all that flavor to
come out
cardamom pods
and then
star anise now these are beautiful whole
star anise
it makes it really nice and fragrant
salt and pepper a lot easier to season
the rice now
than it is once it's cooked you start to
break it up when you season once it's
cooked now it's basically
one part rice to one and a half part
water
600 mils always start off in cold water
cold water in
onto the gas
lid on
bring it up to the ball as quick as
possible and turn it down and let it
simmer for eight to ten minutes and
that's the secret behind cooking great
rice allow it to steam as it's cooking
do not lift that lid up
lid off
[Music]
it smells aromatic basically all the
water's absorbed the rice has doubled in
size and is nice and light and fluffy
take the staranese out
the cardamom pods they all should have
risen to the top
pods out
take your fork
fluff it through
basically it just sort of starts to open
back up
once you've forked it through it becomes
really nice and light and fluffy
and
that is perfectly cooked rice
literally as the stock comes up to the
boil the clams open automatically it
cuts through the richness of the coconut
gives it that nice little bit of acidity
goes fantastically well with the
cinnamon